it is said that those who venture into  white space are cleanse Oh struck all my  fellows what but the key to white space  resides in its celestial Guardian those  who attempt to pass will be met with  vicious resistance but I do not seek  entry I seek revenge  the interstellar fishing vessel ethics  anyway it's no coincidence the ethics  fight can we match the sightings I got a  tag on him won't be long till he's dead  I can't let you do that you will not  stand in my way  I have a guy that will give us five  seasons worth of hauls for this thing  and you expect to get a 16-ton creature  across customs wherever that signal goes  we go are you saying we're about as far  out as anyone has ever gone we got two  options go home empty-handed or get the  grand prize  [Music]  nothing is going to stop us  [Music]  you